منذ بدايه العام الجديد عاشت الضفه
الغربيه والقدس على وقائع اقتحامات نفذها
لاحتلال الاسرائيلي واصفرت حتى اليوم عن
استشهاد واحد وثلاثين فلسطينيا اضافه الى
عشرات الجرح والمعتقلين
استشهد شابان فلسطينيان في بلده كفردان
غرب مدينه جنين خلال مواجهه عنيفا دلعت
بعد اقتحام الاحتلال
قوات الاحتلال البلده وفي الحادي عشر من
يناير استشهد شباني فلسطينيات احدهما في
مخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس والاخر في بلده
الظاهريه جنوب الخليل في الثامن عشر من
يناير استشهد شابا كان في مخيم قلنديا
شماليه القدس وبلده قباطيه بمحافظه جنين
في الضفه الغربيه في الرابعه عشر من يناير
لاحقت قوات الاحتلال مركبه فلسطينيه وقتلت
شابين فلسطينيين في اعقاد اقتحامها لبلده
جبع جنوب جنين وفي الحادي والعشرين من
يناير استشهد فلسطينيون بعد اصابته برصاص
الاحتلال غرب رام الله اما السادس
والعشرون من الجاري فقط كان الاكثر دمويه
حيث استشهد تسعه فلسطينيين في مخيم جنين
الذي اقتحمته قوات الاحتلال في عمليه وصفت
بانها الاكبر ضد المخيم منذ عمليه عام
2002 في المقابل نفذ مسلحون فلسطينيون
عمليات اطلاق نار عده ضد قوات الاحتلال
والمستوطنات لكنها ابرزها بطبيعه الحال
عمليه القدس التي وقعت امس ووصف الاحتلال
بانها الانف منذ سنوات